how about how about this whole thing
about rock you know Oprah Winfrey the
whole story you're hearing about
remember we talked about lordship and
rocks got a massive massive followership
and the guys probably I don't know how
you're a Republican or a Democrat right
this is the this is the real question if
you ran as a Democrat he has to embrace
the democratic base isn't going to
embrace him unless he embraces certain
principles right they would have to
embrace he'd have to go like full
pro-choice which I don't know where he
is on that issue because there's not a
major democratic politician it was not
he would have to engage in a certain
amount of intersectionality which I
don't know if he's willing to do I mean
in the past he's talked about running as
a Republican so I'm not sure whether he
actually would run as a Democrat but if
he ran as a Democrat he won the primary
he'd creamed drum I mean I don't think
that'd be a close election at all
actually because again he's much more
popular because he's must want to like a
bowl by far yeah by a monitor the rack
doesn't cream everybody if he runs I
mean the rocket and by the way he's a
pretty he's a pretty he's a pretty
astute dude he's a pretty astute dude
that was a word I was gonna use he's a
pretty astute dude he's not a
lightweight no I mean he's it you know I
don't know that he's studied up on on
founding ideology but he knows how to
handle himself publicly yes and other
question is that you want that life you
know cuz his life is changed really I
mean his life is so much better now that
it would be if you have why would he
want that library it's a pretty tough
life I mean honestly and also the
campaign is really tough like who really
wants to live off your kids at home for
a year and then just be out on the road
every day for a year that's that's a
really rough lifestyle